hey what up was good how you livin how
you feelin how you doing in his left go
the left go show ready to rock and roll
a great weekend
hope you guys were awesome and I got to
tell you what happened with the results
with the poll results boy did you guys
give me a lot of feedback
thousands of people responded to the
forms I had a lot of people tweeting at
me Instagram DMing me some people very
angry that I would even say that we
should change the constitution I went up
and back with a few people for
paragraphs explaining that this is a
democracy and it is not going to be a
dictatorship I promise I care about the
33% I care about the homies I'm gonna go
through the poll results and then more
than a half an hour of chillin with
Charles Barkley he is the man I'm gonna
get to that as quickly as possible
enough rants out of me and then after
that we're gonna do some football talk
Ryan Fitzpatrick is back Cam Newton whoa
big offseason and why do we hate Big
Bend so much all that's coming up after
Berkeley but let me update you guys on
the polls I asked you simply who is the
greatest quarterback that we have ever
seen amendment number one hand to the
sky look me in the eye pick one guy and
I gave you two options Aaron Rodgers and
Patrick mahomes I said I'm ready to make
the transition to Patrick mahomes you
guys disagreed 36 and a half percent of
you voted for Patrick mahomes 63 and a
half percent of you voted for Aaron
Rodgers combined that's a hundred
percent of the homies voting to retain
Aaron Rodgers as the greatest
quarterback we have ever seen
you have weighed in and I will honor
that it is officially set in stone Aaron
Rodgers will remain the
greatest quarterback we have ever seen I
am saying right now that you know where
I stand on this but this is why I love
the homies you have majority spoken thus
that's what matters we're keeping it
there this is a free-flowing organism it
is a universe I love you we're gonna
stay with Aaron Rodgers the First
Amendment remains unfazed Second
Amendment we're making a change sorry I
came out and said we're moving on from
Kyle Shanahan as our favorite coach in
the NFL and I asked you guys who should
we go with I put eight names on there I
want to give my personal apology to Sean
McDermott I wanted you on the list I
forgot I was too busy finding a picture
of Freddie kitchens and I forgot so I'm
sorry
coming in eighth place
Bryan Flores nobody wanted to jump on
the Miami Dolphins in their tank a
Palooza and crown Brian Flores he with
less than 9% coming in second to last
Vic Fangio you know I had hopes for Vic
Fangio just being the Italian stallion
he is the new head coach the Denver
Broncos but uh he came in seventh in six
Doug Peterson head coach the
Philadelphia Eagles uncle Doug could
have been fun only came in six in fifth
Frank Reich of the Indianapolis Colts in
fourth Andy Reid and now we get to the
top three the top three in no specific
rankings
Bill Belichick Sean McVeigh and Freddie
kitchens coming in third Freddie
kitchens I do love the Browns I'm gonna
go all in on them this season might even
get a Jersey definitely not gonna get a
Jersey I'm not somebody that buys
jerseys it came down to Bill Belichick
and Sean McVeigh Belichick surged out to
the opening lead but he only finished
with 25 and a half percent meaning that
our new favorite football coach with
28.6% of the votes is Sean McVeigh I am
saying this now if you guys disagree I
would need to see strong vitriol in the
comments if not I will officially swear
him in on Wednesday show as our
amendment - favorite coach in the NFL
early congratulations to Sean McVeigh
and if you guys want to hit up Rams and
let them know of his honor please be my
guest
the third and most important thing that
we voted for was who is gonna be my new
football dad and you guys have said in
two different ways that you didn't like
the way I phrase that the number one
vote getter for football dad was Phil
Simms what do you know most over a
hundred votes also I had one of these
comments that said left go you can't
drop Phil Simms stop this with great
power comes great responsibility you can
only get football uncle's to which I
will say I apologize I am changing the
phrase phrasing we are currently looking
for our football stepdad okay
our football dad will always be Phil
Simms the big [ __ ] out of out of
respect but we're looking for a stepdad
and we know what it looks for in a
stepdad gotta be fun
gotta sometimes discipline us when we
need it but not too much you're not my
dad you're my football stepdad but also
give us guidance other names that came
in here that are up towards the top
number two Howie Long was 77 votes you
guys like that in a close third Michael
Lombardo a lot of votes for Michael
Lombardo and I'll be honest he would be
a pretty good football stepdad he'd give
us guidance and he'd also slap us in the
back of the head but not too much but
enough when we need him some of the
other popular ones my dad
Bruce left go got 24 votes and I might
have to call him randomly that's my
actual dad there's no football dads
there but love him he's a great guy
terry bradshaw got 58 votes
but there were some votes that said
anybody but Terry Bradshaw which means
he's polarizing which stepdads can
sometimes be Tony Romo got 28 votes
Archie Manning got 20 votes Boomer
Esiason got 21 which is funny because he
works with Phil Simms got some good
advice someone said why don't you throw
on a football mom add a whole new fan
base bring football to more people not a
bad idea we'll see got some good non
football name's Neil deGrasse Tyson not
sure if he'd be a great football stepdad
he may actually explain how air and
football works and how trajectory could
be interesting Lavar ball I'm okay some
random football names we got Elvis Grbac
TJ Houshmandzadeh Dick Vermeil would be
great but he'd be The Crying football
stepdad his eyes would well up all the
time and he would just be filled with
tears about how the growth that I've
made in my football pursuit some of my
personal favorites Jim Irsay as a
stepdad oh man hey hey let go got an eye
box
let's rip some cigs I'm gonna tell you
about life Jeff Hostetler is just
phenomenal that we might need to get him
again he was the guy that replaced Phil
Simms so making him our stepdad would
actually be great and then I think the
two favorite ones I saw was somebody
wrote Joe Montana with them Skechers
which if I got a chance to interview Joe
Montana again if I only did 15 minutes
on Skechers it would be a career
highlight and the other one I got was
Aaron Donald's dad because let's just
track down a random dad and make him our
football stepdad so Phil Simms you're
still our dad our football dad but we're
looking for a football stepdad and now I
need to call up Howie Long get Lombardi
back in here and Terry Bradshaw we're
gonna audition them first to see if
they're ready to be our dads but now it
is time for our first that's right our
first sports uncle that's right stay
tuned the entire interview with Charles
Barkley to see if he accepted and
listen to the compliments that he gives
me we talked about weed we talked about
basketball versus football we talked
about Samuel Jackson all over the place
but he really complimented me in the
beginning here's my conversation with
Chuck Charles Barkley what's up man how
you doing thanks for having me on the
podcast I want you to know I have a
10-minute podcast so this is an honor I
don't do many podcasts Wow
what's the reason is it like social
media for you you're just not a fan no
there's not that many people I like
enough to want to sit down and talk to
him for a long period of time Chuck yeah
I appreciate that no seriously I like
and I mean I'm not just saying that like
there's very few people that I was sit
down and spend some time with like this
you know you could you talk to the media
all the time it's like hit a miss like
do you think let's move it and
everybody's got a question for you well
hopefully but but like there's very few
people I was like okay I'm gonna take
some time and spend quality time with
you we had a good time at the match we
did have a good time and I was really
surprised what I mean by that is how
easy it was yeah cuz you know like some
time that we had a crazy group oh my
gosh me you Samuel Jackson and Pat Perez
Wilde and the thing is with that group
you fit right in so seamlessly
thanks man that's when I knew you were
legit oh because let me tell you
something when I'm not really good for
my street no no but when I'm around Sam
I'm nervous but he's one of the coolest
celebrities I ever been around makes you
nervous he did in the beginning but now
we've been together for like six seven
years we easy but like and then pat iyer
knowing the past nuts he's nuts
yeah but then you came in it was like
we'd known each other for a long period
of time so and that ain't easy
I got that old soul spear Oh Vegas was
cool we're here right now because of
March Madness yes and they were saying
yesterday that you guys have been doing
this for nine years I can't believe it
it feels like - I feel like people are
still going for three thing at Charles
and Ernie do in college basketball it's
been like a decade now yeah I'm
surprised I thought it was six or seven
or actually like five or six I was
surprised it was nine but let me tell
you some at
March Madness is the second coolest of
it in the world after the Olympics hmm
I've been fortunate go to two Olympics
and I tell people everybody should go to
the Olympics one time in their life but
let's say this tournament the salary at
the Final Four is the coolest thing I do
always you always feel that way or
covering it change your page well I
never I went one time as a player right
and it wasn't that big I was in 82 83
when I went but it's all like watching
from a distance because that's all NBA
players do like now we're gonna be
watching the tournament right you know
start starting this week with the
regular tournaments and like that's like
you know you're off all days we watch
all the games and if you're not playing
you watch the March Madness yeah and in
what's that first Thursday that's a
national holiday
well the Thursday and Friday is national
nightmare is what we call it cuz we're
on television from 12 noon to 12
midnight what people don't realize is
that you guys will be like all right now
here's your halftime show on CBS yeah
and they don't realize you guys are
doing a different one for CBS TBS truTV
you're doing the same thing like four
times yes
and I tell people they're like like I
said did you understand we're on
television or two it really 12 hours
basically straight Wow because we do the
first game by that time it's time for
the kickoff the second game right by the
time you there's time to kick off the
third game you guys don't have NBA games
that night do you know no that Thursday
that would be time and then we do the
four openings because we're on for the
network by the time you finish the
fourth one is half time by the first one
Wow halftime how are you even like
watching we got all the games on so you
bet you're talking you're kind of
keeping an eye on it to know know when
you go to halftime and yeah we were but
once all four imma go on we're watching
all four but you give all the love to
the stat people but they're bringing up
stats but like I said we got four games
on and then you do four closings and
then it's time for the second row of
games
yeah I mean if it's a long the first two
days or just a brutal when I'm watching
now I'm gonna be doing fast break which
is gonna be like online it's good
be like a red zone for college
basketball I'll be in Atlanta doing that
are you in New York
I'm in new yeah when will people realize
that you've officially hit that first
wall what one's gonna get really
entertaining when you're gonna go this
is ridiculous
no I wish they would do it differently
because I want to make sure the kids get
all the energy and love I would like to
see us have two staffs one twelve to six
one six to midnight
I'll be a six but I'm just telling you
though because like it's kind of my
nickname six too many you hit the wall
around probably seven o'clock and then
you get that energy again but like I
want these kids to nothing like you know
for most these kids to last I'm never
gonna play basketball so I really want
them to just really know that we're
really into it yeah you know we've had
some criticisms into what the NBA guys
shouldn't be doing the cotton like yo
first of all if y'all don't wants to do
it that's fine with me I'll go back to
my working my one day a week you know
but you know what we do the best we can
we don't know all the players names but
we know all the basketball stuff I think
the funniest thing is they're like they
don't factor in like RPI and I go do you
guys understand what's entertaining they
don't know and first of all shut the
hell up we give them a billion dollars
they should say thank you for the baby
so I was saying somebody gave me a
billion dollars I was okay sir please do
whatever you hell you want to do the I
would agree with you March Madness is up
there I think what we did with the match
was cool because it was a unique
sporting event if you were doing the
match in other sports like NFL I would
love to see Aaron Rodgers versus Patrick
mahomes in like a classic quarterback
challenge from the 90s hitting targets
all over the place that will be
interesting right yeah and then we'll be
interested
you know the match was just boring they
play bag off bad cops and I think that
feels got more of a personality than
Tiger ain't that funny and and so feel
couldn't get any chemistry going in a
trash talking to any fine talk so that
made it boring and then they didn't use
us enough number one yeah because we are
fools us
and we had Ernie Darren Clarke and Peter
jigs and maybe they were trying to be
like serious I'm like which whoever told
them to be serious and begin and was
stupid yeah hey this is a fun thing
everybody's drunk walking 18-hole oh
it's on the day after Thanksgiving
nobody is and people are sitting at home
with probably drinking and then they
gonna try to make it serious that was
just a stupid idea from the beginning
what would be the NBA match will be the
one-on-one match you'd like to see in
the NBA
LeBron against Katie you know everyday
Ellen Davis against anybody really
mm-hmm
because I think other day was just a
stud as a Shane what's happening in New
Orleans right but it's so many great
russell westbrook against the world man
you're like literally like people just
keep coming out it's just him against
the world yeah and i'll take take
Russell the other thing is so that was
in Vegas and it fells coming to Vegas
man you know Vegas yeah what is that
gonna be like don't think it's gonna be
different you know I want you to be like
an ambassador yeah okay I go to Vegas I
love the gamble you know it's you know
it's so much interesting bull bs is
going on around in sports now listen
it's kind of like the pot thing okay so
I don't smoke pot okay I probably smoke
pot now bro I'll take a smoke pot five
times in my life all of them make me
want eat potato chips and now you see
like pots illegal yeah people who don't
smoke pot hang on smoke pot
it's legal so in NFL NBA NHL MLB it's
legal in where teams play for 80% of
frame but I'm saying though everybody
who don't just causes legal everybody's
not gonna go out a smoke pot right so
we're talking about the gamin thing on
TV a couple weeks ago like now you can
gamble on every block I don't think
people who don't gamble are gonna say I
gotta start gambling now right I hate
those two argument listen if you don't
smoke pot you're not gonna smoke pot
just cause it's legal in your state
yeah and just cause you got gamble
everybody's not gonna start a gallon if
he was gonna gamble like myself we're
gonna we been gambling yeah we're gonna
keep yelling it's just gonna be
interesting going to Vegas they're gonna
have this big new shiny building and
maybe more for like athletes their
hometown is Vegas and now like NFL teams
are gonna go there and on the Friday
night they can be in Vegas yeah but
listen I think the guys got enough
discipline the Antonio Brown in Vegas
it's gonna be amazing
listen I guarantee you and your Browns
been to Vegas many times are ya yeah
yeah yeah and I think you have to be
careful because you're probably gonna be
watched very closely closely yeah you
know as much as I love going to Vegas
I'm not sure how fun it would be to live
there it's interesting yeah I know that
lives there is like we don't go to the
strip yeah you got great restaurants
it's not there it's like the first it's
like Bourbon Street yeah it's like when
I go to Vegas three days is my max and I
vastly stayed longer than three days it
was like please let me go home you know
I've had things to do as I like three
days it's perfect
yeah if you stay more than three days I
think your head would explode I think
it's because of the cycle of people I've
always thought when I go to like I have
to be in Vegas for like summer league
for a week after three days I see all
these people leaving and I go finally
this place is gonna calm down yeah and
there's like a whole new rush comes and
ready to take it to the level I'm like
we need to calm down yeah I just think I
love Vegas
it's just a wonderful place yeah but
listen I might go see the Raiders every
now and then yeah we were talking a lot
of gambling when we were on the desk for
the match I have this thing called left
go locks will make picks what is you're
Charles gambling advice for me to take
my gambling game to the next level oh it
just peaks and valleys you know you're
not gonna win all the time you're not
gonna lose all the time and I hear when
I hate when I hear people say I'm a good
gambler first of all you get bad cars
you're not a good gambler and from my
experience of gambling and the thing I
try it was really helping me I just had
to start realizing you can't break Las
Vegas mmm
you have to go in there with a game plan
so i'ma win some and I'm a loose arm and
keep
been moving what's your favorite sport
for gambling I doubt the tables oh
really uh blackjack and roulette I play
a little back alright but and I
shouldn't be playing roulette but I love
the cards and it's finally oh well know
what's really fun is being there for the
football season in a sports book when
everybody's got where they got every
game on and all hell is breaking loose
that to me is one of the most fun things
to do like me and my boys will go there
on Friday night and we'll spend will get
up in the morning spend a whole day in
the sports book watching College yeah
and then do the same things Sunday man
it is ridiculous how much fun it is to
buy is it because you're just hanging
out with your guys know but just cuz
there's so much energy and juice in the
room first
there's the peak so there's the yelling
yeah there's like people coming around
with food yeah plays you can go like
every game is on but I can say there's
somebody yell over there and that's
exciting I mean I said this to you
yesterday
you you're a level of kindness that is
wild like I when I watch you after the
match it was like the Red Sea parting
like everyone turns it's your size it's
your demeanor all that stuff but then
like you talked to everybody and I'm
meeting these people that are close to
you and I was like I mean these are like
genuinely good people who would you say
are your boys like who was your circle
are they from Alabama like what's your
core that's a great because everybody
thinks they know you yeah but I only got
a few guys I hang out with I got a
brother named boy I hang out with I
should call him but I do
boy my boy Brennan lives in Arizona yes
my boy Roy green ex-nfl player or lives
in Arizona
those two two guys my body's the crew
yeah that's the crew my boy James my
bodyguard
so I dose the people I go to Vegas with
all the time there's a couple other
people I got if one of my friends Bart
he's a vet in Charlotte he come to Vegas
with me in Lake Tahoe wasn't worried but
I don't have I got a couple of people
from high school
that there's a girl named Diane and a
girl named Leslie who I went to high
school with I'm close to my best friend
in high school I said just passed away
John sorry about that was tough man so
we're trying to get through that but he
died a couple months ago and it just
sucks yeah and but he was he's a great
guy yeah yeah so but like I say man I I
try to treat people well you do yeah I
mean I think that's important I think
you know because you got to realize so
man basketball ain't important at all I
tell people if you a teacher fireman
policeman doctor somebody like that
important significantly that's like real
stuff yeah like you should but if you
got like a your opinion on the magic yes
exchange yeah I'm like and I said you
lucky enough just to be able to play a
sport you make more money than you
probably need and deserve yeah and bless
everybody you always thought that or did
it take like you getting older to
realize it because I'm sure when you
were like on the Sixers and 85 you were
like this is everything well that's a
great question
you know I think at one point you're
like I'm rich and I'm famous and you're
like 25 it's gotta be incredible and
you're like it's gotta be more to life
than this you've seen the mountain yeah
late everyone say yeah I haven't done
anything I'm not even that important I
mean like then you have to take a step
back say okay I need to try to do some
good things in life this is just a silly
sport and I really want to do things I
try to help as many people as possible
and I think I'm doing I know I'm doing
good but it's just a never ending story
yeah cuz there's always something new
like right now
I'm here from Alabama we got these
tornadoes that hit last week with 23
people died and we're trying to figure
out like what can we do to help those
people right I mean because this is
second time we got hit by tornadoes we
the ones in Tuscaloosa a few years ago
like man when you visit those places
where tornado hit is it's like
everything you see a news reporter in
the
Aska and one of my first stories I
covered a tornado that wiped out this
town at all
Kansas and when you go beyond like the
crying and the people yeah when you see
it it's it's amazing it's crazy like
everything is flat yes you can't see
anything and it's just all the same
things as everyone yes and it's just you
see rubble and sticks yes and you're
like wow then you realize and like I
realized in Alabama like this probably
is a five to ten year or 15 year yeah
rebuild yeah 100% I mean so you and you
like what can we do this significant to
help these poor people but you know that
not everyone thinks like that right yeah
but you know what that you don't have to
worry about you don't a person you can
one of my great coaches told me
something one time Rudy Tomjanovich and
it's kind of the way I live my life now
and it's not a selfish way but he said
because because I couldn't play anymore
so I got frustrated with some of the
guys on the team and you know when you
can't plant them more it's frustrating
because your mind is like your mind is
so advanced but you can't move yeah and
he says and he says under me when he's
Charles the only person you can control
is you I said what coach he says you
just the only person in this world you
can control is you you do you you can't
try to help these young guys they don't
want to listen they want to listen
that's fine
great I would and I wish they had a list
of me I'm talking about Steve France the
Cuttino Mobley I think things would have
been different for both of them they
both were talented kids but these kids
are not like the generation from what I
grew up where was dr. J and Moses Bobby
Jones Clint Richardson Clement Johnson
Andrew Tony Maurice Cheeks no thing like
everyone I heard about growing at six oh
dude what every time when he says
something to me it was like EF Hutton
was speaking like Charles you need to
learn how to dress I'm like I'm dressing
look this is professional basketball
right you don't wear warmups oops
everyday yeah they're like we wear it
assistant a professional he taught me
how to save my money they taught me how
to be rude to people oh can you teach me
that right now oh like yeah teach me dr.
J's the best I've ever seen
like when like we're having dinner
somebody interrupt you at dinner there's
a nice way you can do it so how did you
do it before they had a doc well no I
never did it in a week and I wouldn't
famous enough but like you know you know
we've been around well guys say hey I'm
having dinner get the [ __ ] away from me
yeah of course I mean I don't want to
call my friends out but I got friends
you did like get the [ __ ] away from
having be honest if you've been in a
situation I understand why oh oh dude
I'm but it's crazy but you can do it
like this dr. J dr. J's on a person I
was saying like hey listen hey Adam I
appreciate you coming to say hello but
I'm having dinner can you please wait to
finish dinner I'll be happy to sign an
autograph and take a picture and I hit
people oh you know what I'm sorry I'm
sorry
and changes just like do yeah just like
that but I've been at a table of guys
who are really really famous in being
lazy yo man get the [ __ ] away from me
I'm trying to have dinner and you at the
table like this yeah kids now everybody
at the table feels like yeah everybody
just spoke forever yeah like it's rude
and uncomfortable yeah but I say when I
say doc taught me like you can tell
somebody no and make it let them keep
their pride in self-esteem right or you
can just [ __ ] on them like some guys do
and I never want to do that I got to
tell them I said hey man listen I'm
having dinner right now let me have
dinner yeah and I promise I'll be as
soon as I'm done with there and I'll
take your picture sign your autograph
because you can't stop having dinner
because then you will never get to eat
dinner yes yeah so are you yeah no but
I'm just saying that's like things like
that
and I tried to pass it on a young guy in
there like Gil man quit hating on me
because you'll get off my lawn guy you
know all are all kids and they take any
time you try to tell us something
constructive yes
we're told get off my yeah you're hater
you're a hater or get off my lawn guy I
do disagree with you on one thing was
that we were talking yesterday I Antonio
Brown yeah what he did to get leverage
yes and you thought he went the wrong
way why I thought it was perfect I don't
think you have to burn down a house if
you want to move I mean if you need but
it but see my thing is I feel like in
the NBA yes we have players that have
all the power right now and I feel like
people assume that the NFL players have
that too and they have nothing like
these guys can't do any
first of all I didn't say I didn't
disagree I said you don't have to burn
the house down if you want to move okay
I mean that's a nice house I mean
somebody that's got to live there yeah
and I thought he really put Mike Tama
and an awful situation
III think of everyone in that situation
I feel bad for Mike Tomlin yes because
it's being made like he's running this
place there's no control and it's what
no because the GM came out and said big
guy yeah but dusted being famous or in
the limelight it ain't right it ain't
fair yeah that's just how it is I tell
these guys all the time I was doing a
show the other day we were talking about
I forget who I forget and we were
talking about championships and I said
people say Charles Barkley didn't win
the championship you've never heard him
say hey Marquess didn't win a
championship or said ceballos I said
that's just how this thing works I'm the
best player I'm gonna the guy I'm gonna
get all the credit and all the blame
yeah debt ain't right betting fair
that's just the way it is
yeah and you cuz we were talking about
Kairi that is that we're talking about
you know he I said that's what I said I
said this guy man he he he was miserable
all the time and he's like I met me
walked in a stadium time but I can't
wait to get away from all this I'm like
yo brah when you're famous you don't get
away from it yeah I just feel like it's
different the NFL I feel like these guys
can't speak their minds as much as they
can the NBA I feel like their contracts
not being guaranteed it's like a huge
burden on like their security and like
how they feel about their future and I
feel like it's a lot more one side in
the NFL no question all the power like I
say I never have first of all I because
I saw what laughs rich Jarrell said and
I thought who's the greatest guy ever he
says I just think a B is going about the
wrong way that's what Larry said and I
agree that's like yo man you do Don have
to burn down the house when you move in
yeah listen I'm glad he got his money I
want all the players to get their money
good but
just thought he handled it the wrong way
because it put Tomlin in an awful
situation I think there's truth to that
wait so you you were an eagle Sam yes
which one I heard that well heart
started fluttering so listen we're an
Auburn guy in college yes and then an
Eagles because you were in there like
your big part of your look was no
because we don't have proteins in
Alabama so really didn't pay a lot of
tension too we kind of vaguely rooted
for the Falcons but it was in Atlanta
close to I like the team of the South
yeah a team of the South but like we got
that one game a week and it was really
never your team so were you in Philly
like was it like you and a Randall
Cunningham oh yeah
Reggie White Jerome Brown self Jonah so
oh it was awesome under a water or
Sixers team in that era had so many
awesome characters and that team was
crazy buddy Ryan also who's my favorite
coach of all time I got a chance to meet
him before I passed and him what a gem
oh just like it just tells it like it is
and let me tell you something you know
players the players loved Buddy Ryan
he'd loved Buddy Ryan I mean I saw that
great piece where Mike Singletary went
down to his house and willed him around
for hours yeah just to visit him every
now and then but because you can lie to
the fans you get a lot to the press you
can't have a lot to the players and let
me tell you something that window when I
was in Philly and we had Ron Hextall in
hockey who could score was yo-yo yeah
Ron Hextall who's my favorite hockey
player of all time Wow
I got a signed autographed jersey from
him I did you know the last couple years
I got a signed autograph judge from Ron
Hextall and Brian Dawkins my favorite
player yeah I'm telling you my favorite
athlete oh you still I got both of them
assign me a jersey and like I think it
was like three years ago yeah but like
man the Eagles were and let me tell you
one thing about Philadelphia no forget
the Flyers the Sixers and the Phillies
yeah I tell that the Philadelphia Eagles
run Philadelphia's running Lake all
right when they want a Super Bowl a
couple years ago you could see like
the whole city just exploded yeah it's
microphone yeah Lex is microphone but
like I tell people you celebrate I did
no because I'm just uh I'm just a fan
yeah I don't have that they hadn't won a
championship ever I was there yeah yes
there was my parents oh oh when I went
to the parade oh oh I was I was watching
from a distance I can say I can't claim
because I didn't I played my first eight
years in Philly yeah so I'm a fan short
but I'm not like I saw people going
crazy I was one of them yeah I was in a
club with the the Lombardi Trophy and
like a cigar in my mouth like I won I
was like let's see it's so profound that
you say that because I want to make a
point and that's what I try to tell
these guys today sports ain't important
but it's really important but the best
thing about sports is no matter how
crappy your life is in Philadelphia no
matter how crappy it is if the Eagles
beat the giant eagle beat a giant that
great and you win a Super Bowl you
forget about all the crap that's going
on in your life I did and that's the
beauty of sports yeah
like even if your team don't win it like
if you have a great season or even if
you win a regular season game for that
24 hours you forget about how that city
embraced Iverson yes he embodied
everything if he can do it I feel that's
the team that's why I was so sports is
not important but it's really important
do you have a good story of being with
Randall and drove around a Reggie White
that can kind of like talk about how
crazy those guys were or how floor
Randall's never been create the craziest
one was wrong Brown glorious soul I've
heard so like what's your what it was
like to roam Brown no because like like
we're all relatively the same age and
you know deputy you want a party in
Philly you can party in Philly
yeah Philly's one of the great cities in
the United States
and just being around those guys they
were large it in life I mean the first
time I met Reggie White I was like and
the fact I can play football he was
little to you yeah Wow I I have no idea
I've never met Reggie I always thought
he was like six nine no I'm taller than
dredgen he had like a little gut and you
were like this is the best defensive
player yes I was like are you kidding me
and didn't you go watch them playing
like oh because you don't have to be
like shrivels really but Syria to be
like great but he was the nicest guy in
the world God rest his soul and I've
gotten yourself join is actually one of
my neighbors in Arizona now and we play
golf all the time but Randall was
unbelievable
I mean you go I didn't but buddy Ryan to
me and I've said to my favorite coach of
all time because the way the players the
players love buddy right huh yeah you
know and like I say I went to a bunch of
flowers games Eric Lindros that was
doing his day how did people react to
you going to hockey games and the fact
that you're a big hockey fan that has to
shock people they listen I love hockey
I'm so excited about the understand
o'clock playoffs or the greatest event
in the playoffs compared to the sport
we've learned today March Madness and
the Olympics are the two greatest who
would a sporting event is one event and
then the hockey is the greatest sports
playoff the playoffs by far play hockey
playoffs or March Madness
Martha madness is the great answer the
PR guys know because the one thing about
bars Mars madness Nate by the way I
don't refer to there's going to be
something that happens every Mars bad is
that you're like wow like like the
sister Jean storyline you can't make
that up they it makes no sense yes I
would never bet on it yeah but then when
it happens we go it's March man there's
more to madness yeah like okay okay they
win a game okay and then she's like on
cameras yeah yes smokes person and then
they win another game that's why I'm
liking the Nevada kids this year yeah I
just feel like twins
I when I'm like betting on the
tournament yeah I'm like those are the
storylines that don't make sense yeah
they're gonna be interviewed by Jim
Nantz yeah we sit with Tracy Wolfson see
but don't like don't say you can't make
those stories out like only in March
Madness you like well a one's gonna be
the six team at some point one's not
gonna lose to a 16 and it freakin and
then it freakin happens and you're like
wow and then you're like okay they got
none left but if any win in next game
Wow you're like okay but see the one
thing I've learned about Mars man
there's a couple things number one while
these coaches can't coach and number two
to three shot is kind of level the
playing field I also think the amount of
time outs changes the game completely
because there's so many TV time but it's
hard to go on a run yeah but the thing
is though they see one of the things
that I'm great at and I like I love just
looking at the strategy and one thing I
know is that and I would never call a
college coach out but some of these guys
got zero strategy like you can tell they
recruit and they say go out there and do
it or be had a game plan and then don't
adjust as it goes on zero adjustments
this is what we do this is what we do
that's the NFL and I'm sitting there
like well it doesn't work against that
team right like that's the beauty like
you plan against this team one game and
then two days later your friend gets a
totally different team you cannot have
the same strategy that's why you know
you know you said that I hear people
talking about the New England Patriots
and said they have a different game plan
every week it's beautiful and but my
question is why don't all the teams do
that think about this the Patriots came
out two years ago and they were a spread
offense last year they draft an
offensive line from Georgia running back
from Georgia they pack it in and they're
a power running office yes against the
Chiefs they ran the ball forty eight
times and threw the ball 44 they're the
first team I looked up that's ever had
those number
before in a year Belichick went were a
power running team because everybody was
getting ready for the spread and they
couldn't tackle that's why he's the best
he's the greatest football coach ever
but my question is you know they always
talk about they switch it up they have a
different kind like I'm like why can't
other teams do that because you know how
people are because it doesn't make sense
to me because I tell people I have to
have a strategy every game yes it's
almost six for power forward what I'm
doing against this guy you can't do it
you can't do it I have to have a
difference so I'm switching up game to
game week to week all my plans and I'm
sitting here like yo man what changed
his plate like sometimes I'll sit there
and watch a game a team of run the same
play five times in a row and then get a
layup or easy shot him like yo man you
got to change the defense on that all
right so I have a request for you we got
to wrap it up because I get a lot of
people they want to talk to you I
recently had to retire Phil Simms as my
sports dad it just it he his son went
somewhere else I got to move on I am
asking you would you like to be my
sports uncle
I feel like uncles are cooler than dads
because you can give advice but also be
like hey I would love to be uncle
because number one you're cool and and
also you're part of the tribe now yeah
so if you've been drafted in so you're
pulling it I get to come to the gut you
get to come to the cookout what do I
need to bring listen man you just have
because if I were a potato salad might
be raisins potato salad raisins we're
from the south
okay hey uncle honker it's official hey
thank you my brother
thank you any time we'll do it again I
would love to oh okay I just needed a
little bit of music after Berkeley
because it felt so darn good I think I'm
gonna really try and get him on a lot
he is our sports uncle I text him all
the time Albarn won the SEC Tournament
I said war damn Eagle he said thank you
buddy and I
anybody I love Berkeley is the man thank
you so much to him thank you to Nate's
amounts of Turner for kind of help set
that up and hey little college
basketball thing this is coming out
Tuesday tournament starts on Thursday I
did do a bracket on March Madness live
the bleacher report bracket check out my
Twitter I put the link you can compete
against me my bracket is called left
coast locks I went with Virginia because
I think they're gonna be super motivated
after being the first one seed to ever
lose I think they're gonna come back I
like them that's my love Cole lock and
you know about left ko locks the other
thing is Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday
I'm gonna be doing like March Madness
red zone with Turner so on like the
March Madness website if you want to
watch online watch with me it's gonna be
me Rex Chapman Andy cats and I think
Tony Delk and we're all hanging out
watching basketball and if there's a big
dunk I'm gonna go alright let's go to
that Virginia game oh what a dunk
hey we got Zion tube they want to make
it like red zone it's called fast-break
so Thursday Friday it starts at 2
o'clock goes all night Saturday and
Sunday starts at 6 o'clock goes all
night I'll be posting links on social to
check it out but yeah your boys doing a
lot of different stuff college
basketball golf NBA NFL whatever you
need I got it and you know what I got
here NFL talk all the time never
stopping never changing and it's the
perfect time to reintroduce a lot of you
guys to whoa
big offseason by the way next time we do
this Nick audio nick has been making
some stuff very excited for you to hear
him so to those of you that do not know
what whoa big offseason is whoa big
offseason is we're getting close to
there it's when stories start coming out
that that fan bases maybe make a big
deal about but they're really not that
important
Braxton Berio spends an extra hour tool
in the jugs machine that one gets
printed up whoa big huff season watch
honey here comes Braxton barrios Broncos
linebacker Josey jewel grew up taking
care of a hundred and thirty cattle
18,000 turkeys and that's why he's going
to be a hard worker whoa
big
offseason when the training camp starts
these stories start Cam Newton is going
vegan whoa big offseason and that's
where we're gonna start we have a
history on this show of NFL players
going vegan and I'm gonna be honest it
hasn't really turned out that great but
every year a new football player decides
to go vegan Theo Riddick went vegan
stayed vegan haven't really heard from
him Demaryius Thomas went vegan stories
came out later that the Denver Broncos
one of the trade them because he wasn't
as strong or as fast because he went
vegan
Benny Fowler went vegan lost 14 pounds
Trent William tackle four Washington
went vegan and then there's of course
the most famous adrian peterson who said
he's going 80/20 vegan because he
occasionally likes to stop off and get
Church's Chicken I mean that's why
Adrian Peterson's the best so we've had
our relationship with vegan and now
we're the best quarterbacks to the NFL
Cam Newton has decided to go vegan and
I'm sitting here and I'm going Cam
Newton must be getting advice from a
very high ranking nutritionist that's
looking into how this has affected NFL
players and how it's gonna change their
bodies and what its gonna be and I saw
the video and here's what Cam Newton
said about why he's going vegan some of
the strongest animals for some of the
strongest species on this earth look at
gorillas when you look at really
elephants hmm you know they find their
source of protein do the same thing and
he does the same thing is Cam Newton
getting his nutrition advice from Planet
Earth gorillas and elephants come on man
company you're not a gorilla or an
elephant you're a you're a human what
what did gorillas get on the three-cone
what an elephants get in the 40 you know
how did meerkats do in the vert I don't
know we're gonna watch the evolution of
cams vegan hood and see how this goes I
have never been more invested in
somebody going vegan because the other
thing is too is when you go vegan you
tell everybody that you're vegan oh hey
are there eggs in the french toast
because I'm vegan Oh what's your side
dishes we're gonna hear about it a lot
be on the lookout for other planet Earth
types of actions Cam Newton vegan hood
whoa big offseason alright I saw this to
Peter Kings football morning in America
he always has his article and in it he
had a line that made me think with Big
Ben I was very hard on Big Ben I was
very pro Antonio Brown
but Peter King had the line that said
quote I think I'm not a big fan of
everyone who ever crossed paths with Ben
Roethlisberger trashing him this came
out because former Steelers running back
Josh Harris claimed that Big Ben
purposefully fumbled in a game in 2014
to spite Todd Haley first of all amazing
the quote was from the running back Josh
Harris Todd Haley called a run play with
very little time left in the game Ben
wanted to Neal he rolled his eyes in the
huddle then purposely fumbled the ball
saying that he put the ball out when the
full-back went by so that it would
fumble it would look like an accident
Josh Harris claims that he had to
recover the ball quote at that moment I
knew what kind of person he was
the problem is Peter this is totally
something that Ben would do when I read
this story he went yet has been
purposely for rolling his eyes in the
huddle purposely fumbling the spite down
Haley I could see him doing it I could
there are so many things that you could
tell me that I could go yep I can see
Ben doing
let's try a few out former Steelers
tight end says Ben used to insult the
lunch lady when the food was cold bro I
didn't get this french bread pizza less
than 32 great like I could see it
former Steelers defensive line coach
says Ben would double Park in Mike
Tomlin spots occasionally totally
totally former Steelers teammate alleges
that Big Ben told the ref that Jesse
James didn't catch the ball against the
Patriots I could see it I could totally
see it you would believe it that's where
we are with Big Ben like did you know
that Big Ben did not visit Ryan shazier
in the hospital during his recovery it's
disgusting but it's also not true and
it's disgusting that you believed it
because that's where we are with Big Ben
that I could he was there all the time
he was visiting Ryan shazier all the
time but you believe that for a second
you did because that's where we are with
Big Ben we've officially reached Big Ben
can do nothing right and personally I'm
hoping that more stories come out
I'm also reminding everybody that any
story could come out about Big Ben and
I'm gonna believe it at this point
Big Ben occasionally picks his nose and
puts it under the desk at the
quarterback facility and blamed it on
Josh Dobbs oh my god sign me up he can
do no right Ryan Fitzpatrick is the
opposite Ryan Fitzpatrick can do no
wrong Ryan Fitzpatrick
officially signs a deal with the
Dolphins it's gonna be like two years 11
million the Dolphins if you haven't seen
in the words of my friend mean at Kimes
they are a fish tank they are tanking
they have gotten no free agents their
quarterback room is like Ryan
Fitzpatrick and David fails they have a
new head coach and they want to tank
probably get a quarterback next year and
I don't know as a Sixers fan I will
never judge teams for tanking personally
I love it gridiron Heights is one of my
favorite things that bleacher report
does Dennis Flynn has been so great at
being the writer and kind of taking that
over you guys know that I was
a bigger part back in the day and really
my main part now is I'm the voice of
Ryan Fitzpatrick I'm going on the fourth
season of gridiron heights now I thought
this was a character that was going to
go away and now I get I keep getting to
be the voice of Ryan Fitzpatrick on
gridiron Heights
I'm telling you it's like it's like Ryan
Fitzpatrick and Tom Brady for most
appearances on gridiron Heights
what's wild is he's now been this is his
eighth team that's one quarter of the
NFL he has been their starting
quarterback which means there's eight
different cities that go I remember I
used to refer Ryan Fitzpatrick and I
just uh he can do no wrong he's he's
like Jesse from Breaking Bad where they
thought they were gonna kill him off and
he kept coming back it's like little
finger you know like every time I watch
Game of Thrones and I know he's dead I
still don't think he's dead he just
keeps coming back he finds his way back
and and as Dennis wrote in the in the in
the episode he's Danny ocean he's the
ultimate con man he always gets it done
but I'm left with three main questions
about Ryan Fitzpatrick number one is he
a Patriots mole think about it he has
now been on all three of the ASC East
teams not named New England Miami
Buffalo the New York Jets
is he a Trojan horse that Bill Belichick
has hired to send around the NFL to
implode to cause front office's to go
maybe the six weeks that he had there in
November in December is sustainable
maybe he is a great leader for our young
quarterback but secretly he's taking all
the snaps and the entire team is gonna
love him and then everyone's gonna want
to move on from Jameis is he a mole is
he a virus that Bill Belichick installs
into his opponents that's my first
question
my second of three questions is he the
perfect tanking quarterback or is he the
worst tanking quarterback ever Connor
Roger stick to football we were having a
meeting exists I think he's the worst
because he
can't control his success he's gonna win
games that you don't want to win
he's unruly he's unpredictable you can't
control his magic that's what magic is
that's why he's fits magic no one knows
where it's going where it's come from or
how to stop it or is he the perfect
tanking quarterback because he'll get
the random win over the Patriots and
then lose to Buffalo by 25 because he'll
be up 20 in the first half and then lose
by 10 because he'll throw you out of the
game also if the coach came to wiring
Fitzpatrick and said Ryan we're beating
the Texans by 17 code fish tank
Fitzpatrick would go out there in the
second half and throw four interceptions
two four pick sixes and nobody would
question whether or not he was throwing
the game not us he's the only
quarterback in the NFL that if he threw
for four touchdowns in the first half
and four pick sixes in the second half
nobody would question him for throwing
the game even Vegas would go that's what
happens when you bet on really
Fitzpatrick nobody that's why I think
he's the perfect tanking quarterback the
key though is you need to have a backup
that's not as good as him and the
Dolphins have a backup who's literal
last name is fails like it doesn't get
better we're not gonna go WOW they
should be playing Jameis no no no
they're not putting in fails my last big
question is why is he the only
quarterback that we support stealing
money from franchises we never get mad
at interception three of the last four
jobs he's taken very intelligently by
the way did you know that he has a
Harvard education were in places that
had no state income tax Houston
Tampa Miami genius making money on top
of money he's currently at 58 million
dollars after the 11 million dollars
from Miami what do you know everyone's
favorite number 69 million dollars in
career earnings 69 damn near 70 men Ryan
Fitzpatrick has made Newt damn near
70 million and I never hear fans upset
about it it's awesome it's awesome it's
really incredible we cheer this guy on I
don't know if it's because we relate to
him I don't know if it's because he's
got the beard and people find beards
funny I don't know if he's just like
this amazing guy but like he's the only
professional athlete where we're
actively rooted go get that money Raya
and steal more money from another team
and it's it's amazing I I really go back
to the Steelers game where they're
beating the crap out of the Steeler no
no though they're getting their butts
kicked by the Steelers they're down 20
and that quote came out that he leaned
over to Mike Evans they're down 20 and
he leans over and he goes for some odd
reason I love [ __ ] football I love it
and Evans said I don't know why about I
looked at my said I'm with you I love
football too and they're both down 20
and that was the same game where that
incredible gift came out of him just
going oh and Ryan Fitzpatrick just loves
[ __ ] football and that's why if
they're tanking or if they're winning 11
games if he's making 11 million dollars
or $11 if he's throwing you to the Super
Bowl or throwing you into the first pick
in the draft he just loved [ __ ]
football and that's what we do left go
show just loves [ __ ] football and
Ryan Fitzpatrick I salute you you're
incredible 33% you guys are incredible
thank you so much for all of your help
for the amendments Aaron Rodgers will
continue to be our favorite quarterback
to watch the NFL the best quarterback
we've ever seen Nick get that funky
music I'm just saying right now Sean
McVeigh is going to be our favorite
coach in the NFL if you've got a problem
with that let me know if we need to do a
one-on-one balichek versus McVeigh let
me know but he got most of the vote I'm
happy to make it coming up on Thursday I
have an interview with a very good NFL
player but until I record it tomorrow
I'm not saying his name because I don't
jinx that type of [ __ ] you guys are
awesome I am the lef koe and we will
holla holla holla atcha later be walls
[Music]